hi and welcome to serverless migration
station i'm wesley from google joined by
my colleague martin to help you navigate
the world of migrating from one product
to another usually as it relates to one
of our serverless compute platforms
today porter will show us the optional
migration from cloud datastore to cloud
firestore oh really another optional
migration what's wrong with you people
i know right to be fair we did let
developers know in the module two and
three videos that python 2 apogen
developers really only need to move from
the original ndb library to cloud ndb
doing so makes it easier to port
applications to python 3 and also get
them on cloud datastore the standalone
nosql solution that grew out of the
original app engine data store
since the cloud ndp client library works
with python 3 app engine users would
only further migrate to cloud datastore
or cloud firestore client libraries if
they had a really good reason to do so
oh yeah i think i remember
but can you remind me sure martin both
the cloud ndb and cloud datastore client
libraries access cloud datastore the
underlying database
cloud ndb was created specifically for
python 2 apogen developers as a
migration tool while python 3 and
non-app engine users are directed to
cloud datastore immediately so
developers should only migrate from
cloud ndb to the cloud datastore client
library if they already had code using
it meaning it's where you want to
consolidate to using just one client
library to talk to datastore
ah that's right uh thanks for the
reminder um but uh now what about
today's migration to cloud firestore
glad you asked martin well there's good
news and then there's bad news uh oh uh
well i'm an optimist uh what's the good
news wes well cloud data store became
its own product in 2013. the following
year google acquired firebase for its
amazing real-time database
both teams then worked together and
launched the next generation scalable
nosql database in 2017. to show that
datastore joined forces with firebase
the product was rebranded as cloud
firestore
oh yeah and you told me to wait until
this video to learn more so here we are
you also mentioned that firestore is
fully compatible with datastore and that
all datastore databases will be
converted to firestore under the covers
is that right
ah yeah martin once converted they will
be operating in datastore compatibility
mode or firestore in datastore mode for
short this mode however does not give
you access to firestore's native
features only data stores in order to
access all of firestore you need to be
running in firestore native mode
similarly when prompted to create a new
nosql datastore you get to choose
between firestore and datastore mode or
firestore in native mode
check out the chart in the docs to see
the differences between them oh i see so
all users need to do is switch from
firestore in data store mode to
native mode and i good right
but i think i'd better ask now what's
the bad news you mentioned yeah i think
you know what i'm gonna say
you can't switch between datastore and
native firestore modes once the mode is
set and data is stored the mode is
locked also the compound matters
datastore and firestore are mutually
exclusive in gcp projects meaning that
once the mode is locked not only can you
not change it but in order to use the
other mode you need to actually create a
brand new project
so what you're saying is if i got data
in datastore
even if i migrate to the cloud ndb or
cloud datastore client libraries i'm not
able to use cloud firestore in native
mode unless i
create a new project with a new app
select firestore in native mode in that
new project
dump the data store data out of my
current project
and load it into firestore in the new
project
yep you got it and now you know why this
is even more optional than moving from
cloud ndb to cloud datastore at least
with that migration you don't have to
create a brand new project but this one
does require that and it doesn't matter
if it's an app engine app cloud run or
even a non-cloud app using datastore you
have to have a new project
so once again you really need to have a
good reason to make this migration and
if accessing those firebase features is
compelling enough you got to do what you
got to do right
yep that's right well i do want to take
advantage of firestore's native features
and i'm willing to create a new project
to make it happen
how do i get started well the first
thing is you must recognize there are
two pieces to this puzzle
first your data must be transferred from
datastore in your current project to
firestore in the new project that's part
one
secondly it probably goes without saying
that you need an app in that new project
that uses the firestore client library
okay i got it but before we do that i
remember from what is was it module
three that the cloud datastore client
library can be used by both app engine
and non-app engine apps is that true for
cloud firestore as well
yeah definitely martin while we're going
to demo migrating an app engine app to
cloud firestore it could be any app
really the only real requirement is that
you have to have a new project and since
you mentioned module 3 that's where we
created our cloud datastore app so we're
going to migrate that one to cloud
firestore specifically the python 3
version as python 2 apps are more likely
to be using cloud ndb instead so if you
did the codelab use your code or grab
ours from the module 3b folder by either
cloning the repo or downloading the zip
file pause here if you need to but once
you're ready let's go to the computer
now
okay before we start we need another
cloud project for firestore so make a
new one in the cloud console or reuse an
existing one where neither data store
nor firestore are used grab that
project's id not the project name nor
number the id then enable the cloud
firestore api if you prefer the command
line use gcloud projects create then
change to that new project with gcloud
config set and finally turn on firestore
with gcloud services enable of course
you'll be asked to enable billing as
well since we always suggest you start
with working code deploy the module 3
python 3 app whether you're using yours
or ours but do this from your old
project the one using datastore
use gcloud config list to see your
current project and use gcloud config
set if necessary once you're on your
data store project run gcloud app deploy
and confirm the app works like before
now switch to your new project with
gcloud config set project one more time
as we'll be here the rest of this
migration starting with the
configuration files
the only config you need to change is to
switch from cloud data store or cloud
ndb if you're using that to cloud
firestore there should be a one-line
swap in requirements.txt
all other changes are in main.py replace
the cloud datastore client library
imports and api client instantiation at
the top with the same for cloud
firestore groups of like entities in
datastore are identified with a common
parent key entities in datastore are
referred to as documents in firestore
entities are of a certain kind in
datastore while firestore documents are
grouped as collections when starting a
new visit in datastore a new entity is
created with the visit parent key
likewise on the firestore site we set
our collection to the same name as a
datastore parent key the datastore
entity gets its data key value pairs in
the same way that a firestore document
does but the latter gets added to the
collection immediately while the
datastore entity has to be written
explicitly next are the datastore
queries where you query for visit
entitykinds the desired ordering then
fetch and return for firestore query the
visit collection specify the ordering
fetch and convert to python friendly
dictionaries then return as a memory
friendly iterable believe it or not that
wraps the changes necessary to switch
from cloud data store to cloud firestore
the real work is in having to create a
new project so what do you think of that
migration martin
that migration wasn't too bad at all
but earlier you said any app can use
cloud firestore if i'm willing to create
a new project to access firestore and
take the effort to migrate my data over
does this mean i can rewrite my python 2
data store app as a node.js firestore
app absolutely martin your data store
app could be app engine cloud run or
even non-cloud it's not like the old app
engine days where if you're using
datastore it had to be an app engine app
that's certainly not the case anymore so
the same applies to your new project
meaning you can have any app using
firestore as its database
so if your company is doing more work in
node.js today there's nothing wrong with
rebuilding or refactoring as a node 16
cloud runout for your new firestore
project that's what we mean by app
engine and really all of google cloud as
a whole being more open than ever before
for both your data and for your apps
that's really interesting i've been
thinking about doing exactly that as my
team is doing more with node.js these
days anyway now that i know how to
migrate my app to firestore what about
migrating my data
definitely martin we're going to tackle
that in module 10. while you're waiting
for the data migration sql here are some
additional resources to consider
earlier we link you to a chart
differentiating datastore in firestore
native modes above that chart is our
guidance on which of those modes to
choose for your apps so check that page
in the docs and you know just look over
all of the firestore docs anyway to
become familiar with your brand new
nosql database
also check out this other video from one
of our colleagues that dives deeper into
the migration and the differences
between datastore and firestore cool
i'll check those out
now are there other migrations i should
consider for my app engine app well
first you can see from this list we've
already migrated from our old app into
nato store and ndb to cloud nab cloud
data store and now cloud firestore
however if you're on cloud neb you can
migrate directly to cloud firestore
there's no need to migrate first to
cloud datastore and then go from
datastore to firestore just combine
module 3 with this module 6.
as far as other migrations go if you're
thinking about containerizing your app
engine apps to run on cloud run go and
check out modules four and five
modules seven eight and nine help you
learn about how to migrate from app
engine task queue to cloud tasks
finally if you've got a small app that's
just one function or a big app that you
want to break up into multiple
microservices consider migrating to
cloud functions you'll find that in
module 11. ah thanks for the pointers
there are so many ways to upgrade
oh that's definitely true we want to
give our users lots of options and thank
you viewers for staying with us on these
journeys modernizing your serverless
apps this is wesley from google cloud on
behalf of martin importer hoping you'll
join us soon at the next migration
station or on a different serverless
expedition soon please like and
subscribe to see more content like this
and until next time happy travels
[Music]
you